click on state home to some of the most
productive avocado orchards in the world
but Michoacan is also home to several
criminal groups who pose a threat to the
livelihood of avocado producers truck
drivers like Jesus Quintero say they're
not strangers to criminals on the road
looking for an easy target
they would rub out trucks to steal the
fruit and sometimes they would steal the
trucks too that is the danger on this
stretch of road
to curb the problem State Police now
provide escorts for trucks carrying
avocados between the Orchards and a
shipping facility in the city of Uruapan
while the encroachment of criminal
groups is still a concern Farmers like
Jose evaristo Valencia say the situation
has improved
there were many robberies on the way
from the orchard to the packing house
many trucks were lost and the main
person affected as the producer because
the product doesn't reach its
destination police in Michoacan say they
escort around 40 trucks of avocados
every day but despite more police
truckers say they're still the
occasional highway robbery oh yes one or
two trucks have been stolen but not
daily every eight days yes the theft of
trucks has decreased a lot around here
in Mexico avocados are known as green
gold being one of the country's most
beloved agricultural exports and ahead
of the Super Bowl in the United States
where guacamole is considered a
must-have on the snack menu avocado
production in Mexico is in full swing
annually Mexico sends an estimated 3
billion dollars worth of avocados to the
U.S with the Super Bowl representing one
of the most profitable weekends of the
year
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera